welcome to this video this is
crystalline yeah Christ whatever so um
I'm black and this is the new audio jack
set up which hopefully is ok I have that
I have an impression that it's still
somewhat different then when I did this
test recording last night I didn't
change anything though yeah so what is
he doing 85 never seen that move check
it seems you are taking what the night
that that's a very common strategic
mistake that players make the night is
just completely misplaced on d to it is
a mistake it's not like white losses so
because of the move but it just hidden
does his charges charges considerably
the night belongs on c3 here and queen
on d two so you should always take with
the Queen so let's see do I go if I've I
can't let you five immediately but ok
it's not not really necessary
intending to go e 5 of course getting
pawns on dark squares yeah that is a
move but I am for thinking it isn't
particularly great here it's got the
quiz he gets the Queen on your foyer
maybe that is the point yeah okay so
planning planning um we should be three
I guess I can also play a five hats not
bad takes Knight eggs with the tempo and
then e five next it's not bad g6 weakens
the dark squares quite a bit I'm not
sure how bad it is though okay let's
play that move and I'm let's not remove
he might move the Queen would be a bad
move but he still might do it okay yeah
off [ __ ] my bishop opened up on C aid
and Joe that looks quite okay also
threatening e4 here I think after piece
takes Bishop f5 would win a piece so he
probably will cancel anyway in this
position no he's not canceling okay
yeah keep it simple this is the simplest
way to do it just leading to an about
equal position yeah I guess I shouldn't
have allowed ephi huh that would have
been a bit better
so let's see that you five pawn it's not
terribly weak but it has to be taken
into account Knight to f6 something like
this king of 798 ok here's f4 sometimes
yeah that is a bit it is a bit of a
problem that porn
okay maybe that maybe just do this for
94 on yeah oh it takes it after which i
should be able to handle that position
okay
yeah allowing if five was I wasn't a
good idea in the in the opening stages
of that game
so does he doing don't get it really
why is he going to see five right Yes No
square yeah sure completely just jumping
right into into this where he has no
square to go threatening be six but he
has rook t1 and Bishop f5 salaam
threatening to trap that piece Oh is he
going f3 is that the idea that could be
the idea no hey I don't get it sorry I
fancy stuff replays fancy moose okay
where is he going then to before
okay let's attack that pawn down c4
home
I don't quite sure why you played that
this innocence is somewhat tricky
fashion that really net anything a night
before now okay c5 I can take as a week
back rank and then want to go see five
now myself
yeah what you for next attacking see
form
I was surprised by many moves here I'm
not sure I again is playing some some
trickin booyeah okay so i can at the end
i get this right so i can just can just
play like that with at the end i get
this i meant this move well actually
didn't see that a for was hanging that's
a bit embarrassing check
Jim check chattin connected prawns is
quite quite much c3 which is king is
quite near January time morning I'm just
going to play on my pawns not cover
stuff yeah bonus is promoting check
check
white resigns okay so let's let's have a
have a look what happened down yeah
night XO that said it's not not
particularly great but I made a mistake
yeah actually I'm castling a bit too
quickly am it's a better idea to try to
get an e5 quicker or just play if I've
ever said if 196 I can also just start
with this move and then play you five
the thing is that this night is just
looking at things that we need to test
no scope that has to be on c3 to being
able to look at important squares and
detours it's not very well placed I
maybe should have played a five here
this is probably a good idea as grabbing
the pawn is usually a bit risky yeah
maybe it's not super bad for wide in
this position but now I get this in but
cut my doubts okay knight c6 aunty Wendy
five that was interesting take stakes
and here yeah so I went Queenie seven
you can actually think about the move
here immediately so that in this kind of
position he doesn't even have Bishop to
d3 this is probably better the other
computer actually just make big edge
here pretty surprised yeah maybe I get
in Bishop f5 and it's not so clear I
mean he cannot do if you place something
simple let's say I had before maybe that
was really better that that looked
normal but KF five and to think it's
about equal here Queen D ages the
computer suggestion yeah yeah why not
actually I mean 328 is a bit peculiar
attacking the bishop but the computer
basically wants to allow what to take on
f6 it's probably a better version of the
game in the game it was some guy it felt
a bit a bit uncomfortable and here here
yeah now the comp gives c5 with an
advantage 9c for coming yeah that looks
a pretty good for wider that makes lots
of sense now that's true John yeah I
shouldn't have taken only four probably
so night at five he took it yeah i know
i will pay announcement but you have to
switch off that that messages again yeah
but all those maneuvers were kind of
kind of weird i had root a5 already how
that was bad and bad in terms of
candidate moves I should have seen that
idea he has to do this not to loose
material it's not very attractive back
and and here I must start to be be
better g5 yeah I wasn't sure if he has
to do this but that's the worst end game
for him I mean what I probably should
hold but it's it's Jack it's tricky the
pods are quite far advanced and here
check exactly I think actually that that
should be winning the pawns are too
quickly either the engine gives me a win
here yeah so he could have played much
better out of the opening giving giving
him some advantage but I should have
played f5 earlier with with a decent
position okay well thanks for watching